[Music]
thank you hello and so yes my name is
Jessica Tran I am from Montreal I'm
currently a student studying computer
science and physics and today I'm going
to talk to you about my anxiety and self
monitoring through technology so I want
to preface this by saying that me and my
anxiety are not friends in the very
least to get a sense of our relationship
imagine you have an ex and you guys
aren't on good terms but you share a lot
of the same friends so you end up at the
same social gatherings as much as you
want to avoid it or avoid them to have
fun you can't so that's sort of a
metaphor for my anxiety is for most
people's biologically my heart begins to
race my palms get sweaty my brain starts
slowing down all processes and in fact
this is not special at all it's a
universal symptoms if you have a healthy
brain and body so to get a longitudal
sense of how long I've been dealing with
anxiety let's address my biggest
childhood fear this is a big therapy
talk for all of us and one of my biggest
fears was that I might forget how to
breathe and this sounds really really
dumb but I was like 5 or 7 or 9 or some
odd number I would spend hours
concentrating really hard on my
breathing just in case the little guy in
my head would forget to pull the lever
and you all thought about this guy when
you're young but of course I eventually
learned that breathing is an automatic
physiological function as I hope all you
have it lies in the same domain as
blinking hunger
our exhaustion it's a way that our body
automatically regulates so that
cognitive resources can be spent towards
higher thinking problem-solving
nonetheless even at my ripe old age of
23 I still worry about my breath and
over intellectualize it to the point it
comes becomes really irregular and
that's again very natural like if I were
to ask you right now to pay attention to
your breath you would also probably get
into an a rhythm so we can try it out
please pay attention to your breath are
you inhaling and what about exhaling are
you on tempo did you remember to inhale
okay so that was above exercise but now
imagine me doing that to you constantly
all the time at any moment that's what
my anxiety is like and this is my life
but I really really love to
problem-solve
which is one of my greatest strengths
and I tried to address this problem and
the best way I know how which is through
a mix of psychology philosophy and
JavaScript so starting with psychology
there's some studies that show a
correlation between breath and mood
basically when you're a heightened state
like fear or anxiety your breath rate is
going to quicken and studies have showed
in more recent years that this is a
bi-directional mechanism meaning while
the mood can change your rate of breath
your rate of breath can also change your
mood which is really really cool but
we'll get more into that a bit later so
qualitatively these I wanted to parse
out the distinctions of my mood so I
just wrote out things when I'm anxious
and when I'm happy and about last year
late last year my anxiety was getting
really difficult to manage I moved to
new city I wasn't fitting in school
wasn't going to great
Mountain naren support etc etc a few
strands of stress I can deal with like
most people but eventually it compounded
and got in the way of like simple
functions like eating sleeping being
able to leave my house and ultimately
being productive and it's lost all these
things these small things that made me
happy and led to a depression which is
what I like to call the anxiety
depression cycle you can't do things
that you feel you ought to be doing
therefore you feel bad and then you get
that two points I want to address real
quick this is one of the hardest parts
about dealing with mental health and one
of the factors I really try to address
in this experiment secondly I don't want
to simplify mental health I recognize
there are a ton of intersectional
biological environmental and
sociological sources that harm and
continue to harm people I myself am
affected by factors nonetheless I carved
out this particular aspect because it
was the easiest to do we meet and target
because I'm a person to really like to
take things apart to put them back
together I figured this was the right
way to start and my next step was to
figure out the mechanism behind this and
what it means to be productive so that
brings us to four code synoptic on so if
you don't know what the pen opticon is
and or if you do know what the Tam
Opticon is and you haven't read this one
and punished by Michel Foucault you
probably have the idea wrong which I
only point out not to be a dick but just
because I had it wrong a few months
myself before I was gracelessly pointed
out to me that it was not correct unlike
the way that I'm doing now so there's a
common misconception with the pen optic
on that's presented through mainstream
media that makes it an analogy towards
the surveillance society I'm sure you've
seen all the sensational articles of
this is what's going on the government's
watching you this is the ten off to go
on and one of the great analogies of
this forum from Lord of the Rings while
most of these analogies do mesh very
well with
original idea it has this quality that
humans do in which we attribute
characteristics such as villain villany
villany evilness which I want to very
much frame right now that that is not
the case and to call himself in the very
beginning of his novel writes that we
should not view power and surveillance
as a negative thing in fact it was first
introduced as a humane way to maintain
social order as opposed to public
torture and violence and while now it's
arguably invisible and still violent if
we should view it as a neutral and
malleable mechanism we can use it for
our own positive production of reality
so here's my very quick crash course on
pan top pan off the column ISM the
panopticon is named after jeremy
bentham's architectural proposal of the
ideal prison so it's a cylindrical
structure which is a prison and around
the cells we have open-faced cells and
in the very center we have a guard just
one single guard in this tower it's
protected by trick glass so the guard
can see out but the prisoners cannot see
in in this mechanism this is the most
ideal and efficient uses of power
because this possibility of always being
watched will imbue the prisoner with an
anxiousness to behave well which should
by the power of the pen octagon lead to
the development of our own
self-monitoring for good behavior
the panopticon is polyvalent means that
the guard could be changed for anybody
your school teacher your parents your
sibling your friends that guy on Twitter
anyone and it would still function
without interruptions each node in this
network can be swapped out and replaced
at any given time which is what makes
so pervasive and powerful with the
perception that everyone or anyone could
be watching you you must fulfill your
social contract and the pen offs Khan
rests on this power of observation
to form good habits so by definition
Foucault's time hasta con is just a way
to enforce a specific behavior and it
can take many forms so for example
schools hospitals prisons the new
language of listicles ten ways to make
yourself more productive social networks
etc it sounds a little scary but it's
not it's actually meant to condition
oneself for self discipline so using
this and combining it with Pavlov's dogs
which I'm sure all of you know the
classical conditioning mechanism it's
just the saliva and the trigger and the
response you have a really good recipe
to improve one slice and combining this
with with with heart rate variability
it's a very nice slide I I created an
app anyways so the time Mouse con itself
is just an amplifier for things already
exist it's not scary it's more like not
so much like Sauron but more so like
this cerebral from x-men and so in the
wrong hands can be very destructive and
exploitative but it can be also being
used for good we're so what we're going
to do so to get into the technical stuff
heart rate variability what is it so
when you inhale your heart rate
increases and while you exhale your
heart rate decreases and if you plot
this on a time function you get a really
nice line and it's very distinct and
just an FYI the y-axis is your inner
beat interval which is the time in
between each beats and this is not to be
mistaken for BPM which is beats per
minute and it's just an approximation
the próximas asians and so
one of the reasons why I got started
with this project was a my anxiety got
pretty bad bi was actually doing a
internship through node with outreach e
and we're working on node serial port so
I wanted to do a fun little project to
figure out how this codebase worked at
all and I settled on something that was
beneficial for me I wanted to do a live
demo but my my pulse sensor didn't work
really well so in short what I did was I
just use node serial port a bunch of NPM
no packages and I designed this like
this little heart rate monitor on my CLI
and read it in my heart heart rate so
I'm sorry if you can't see that line
really well but this is me breathing at
a resting heart rate so this is just me
not doing anything at all and you can
kind of see naturally as we know as you
breathe in and exhale your heart rate
goes up and down plot that it's going to
go up and down but it's not very
predictable and there's no way to like
really put this into an equation however
if you breathe really deeply and
regularly you can increase you can
create these really beautiful sinusoidal
wave lines and this increase of
amplitude and this consistency of the
graph is sort of the heart of this
project and this is called heart rate
variability as you can see the amplitude
is a lot higher than what it was before
and studies show that the greater your
heart rate variability the better your
physiological health which leads to your
better psychological well-being and that
includes depression stress management
anxiety management cardiac health so
this is just a video for me oops doing
some breathing exercises and at
as you can see here the metronome this
is false net or also six cycles per
minute which is what is called a
resonance frequency resonance frequency
is basically just the most efficient
rate that you can breathe to really
select your breathing systems also known
as your autonomic nervous system so this
is this a simple graph you can determine
reson if you can determine your
residence frequency by just going
through different cycles so you can
breathe at four cycles per minute four
point five five five four five six and
as you can see on this this plot line
six is the highest it just dips right
before five point five just a really
beautiful beautiful graph and so the
best amplitude is your greatest HRV for
most people it is six cycles per minute
and or 0.1 Hertz if you throw through a
limp laughs function and even if you are
at like five point five or six point
five you could still do around six and
still get the same results so what can
we do with it we can basically just
exercise our breathing mechanism to
really flex our ans or automatic nervous
system if you do this this has been this
has been done multiple times through a
lot of different studies through
different different groups at healthy
function ask elites to depressed
individuals you do this resonance
frequency breathing 20 minutes a day
maybe 40 minutes a day with some
intermittent biofeedback training and it
can prove improve your mood regulation
your anxiety etc etc very very cool but
one of the biggest and most important
factors I find is that through this
training the effects are chronic and
persistent so say you do this for a few
weeks you stop the effects will be long
lasting I'm not too sure what the decay
is that hasn't been studied but it's
still worth even if you're not doing
these breathing
which fun really cool so this is just
your regimen 20 minutes of residents
breathing daily some weekly relaxed
breathing which is just you you watch
the visual graph of your ibi coming in
the one that i showed earlier and you
just inhale as the line is coming up and
when it reaches the crest you just
exhale and that's relaxed breathing and
you do that very regularly in this
trained your ans and so I tried to
couple this with a monitoring system by
sending this up with a Bluetooth Arduino
to calculate my average rolling heart
rate which worked really well just by
integrating values for resting heart
rate in resonance training but it was
really really hard to calculate in real
world scenarios the reason being as your
breath quickens the variance of your
heart rate actually begins to Plateau
from lack of variability so it becomes
very algorithm is add algorithmically
very hard to determine your breath
cycles per minute without a huge margin
of error and one accurate way to measure
this is to have been purchased a
respiration device that like connected
to your chest or to your nose but I
didn't so instead I use the principles
of the panopticon because of course it's
polyvalent it can use in any way and I
designed this experiment to get my
controls I would do specific things to
exasperate my anxiety like just very
difficult psychological things like
pinch myself post things online that I
really wouldn't normally do things that
that make me nervous inherently so
here's a few examples this is just a
recreation that i did but i did do
things like this was just message people
that I liked and measured in my heart it
this didn't go anywhere just so you guys
know and
and so I also tried to program or I did
program my own panopticon's meaning well
it was more so what you could call yet
another productivity tool so remember
the panopticon does not necessary to
clogs an observation it's merely
perceived constant observation
so again leveraging my social anxiety I
used a bunch of NPM packages to do to
program a cron job to check if I was
doing my daily logs and I prescribed a
set of pure set of punishments for
myself if I didn't do it by a certain
amount of time so like my first year was
like I would I wrote out all these
things to send myself that like you know
when you're not doing the things that
you're doing you're really angry and
you're saying to yourself like I just
call myself awful human being which
wasn't very nice but you know that was
that was the punishment I would send out
in Dane tweets to Twitter land although
I recognize this is just how Twitter is
so it wasn't really a punishment tr3 I
had a bunch of like embarrassing things
to send to like crushes or like exes you
know and thankfully I never reached here
but like that would have been pretty
much the worst for many reasons so so
ultimately the experiment was a
redundancy of a lot of different methods
so a I used the exercise that have been
tested to shown improvements of mood
regulation and I experimented with my
anxiety coming in and measured it which
was a form of exposure therapy or a
rejection therapy
I built this accountable accountability
mechanism to watch over me or my own
personal panoptic on and also the act of
writing down those thoughts that I had
was a bit therapeutic so I guess the
question here is was it successful I did
go from like a 24 resting heart rate or
for a minute - like 20 - but I don't
know if that's like really important to
note but essentially part of the
experiment I self observed that I
haven't improved control of my thoughts
and ruminated a lot less I can I feel
that I can distinguish when I'm getting
anxious or am in a state of anxiety and
instead of using self coping mechanisms
that didn't really solve the problem I
just employed this breathing technique
which is what I was doing for this talk
actually and a bit of less less social
anxiety and ultimately improved my
feelings of F's keys efficacy across all
areas I want to note though that before
you try this at home and if you do plan
to and there are some really important
factors that could have contributed to
all these positive effects which was so
I got used to the new city I built a
meaningful real I began therapy for the
first time I exercise and I decrease a
lot of my stressors from school work
ending and so again with mental health
it's hard to through and figure out what
which factors are the main ones and what
has the alchemy to to improve so in
conclusion I wanted to wrap this up
meaningfully but I didn't want to end up
saying something like me and my anxiety
are now best pals because I feel like
that's a false optimism and frankly just
not true
if I could choose a physiology in which
I didn't experience debilitating anxiety
it didn't have to think about it this
hard and didn't have to do so many
things to manage
kind of ten times out of ten no question
I would definitely choose that body but
nonetheless this is just who I am and so
what I have in closing for you instead
is this clip from Star Trek because I
feel like best show just says think that
wish I could say all the time and says
it's so much better and if you're
unfamiliar with the show all you need to
know well first familiarize yourself and
all you need to know about this is that
as it features data an Android who's
like perfect in every way except that
he's not human and in this particular
clip he is speaking to his Android
daughter who also shares this flaw and
so alright and that's the end of my talk
thank you for listening
thank you so so much